ci stanno dentro cose che ti magni
benissimo che sembrano cose molto peggio
di questo nome quindi tu stai proponendo
di assaggiare i croccantini del cane
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata ora abbiamo finalmente
compreso dopo mesi e mesi di convivenza
ecco e di comunione con con voi che ciao
ragazzi bentornato in una puntata di
cucina ha buttata ora il tempo faccia
ciao ragazzi ben tornati alla nuova
puntata di cucina buttata abbiamo
finalmente capito qual è il messaggio
che veramente ha unito tutte quante le
nostre puntate tutte quante le nostre
ricette ossia che non siamo capaci di
cucinare per gli umani almeno rischiamo
il più delle volte di avvelenare il
prossimo tutte le persone che ci seguono
ecco perché siamo giunti a una
conclusione smettere di cucinare no
iniziare a cucinare per un'altra razza
oggi proveremo a fare delle croccanti
delle croccanti né gl krug engine e dei
croccantini per cani e dal momento che
per quanto enrico rispettarlo e l'inter
è di farli mangiare i croccantini
abbiamo qui un ospite d'onore che forse
sentirete di sottofondo durante il video
gold e che stia zitto proprio nulla e
qui salsiccia di non sentirmi
chiaramente che lui è meraviglioso cool
di
sei pronto tu oggi a farci da
assaggiatore missiva che c'è
continuamente su un posto dove si cucina
vai a farti cavoli tuoi rimettetelo sul
divano così ti osserva mentre vicini la
palma ma si vedono lunetta che così di
gelo che se ne deve andare in curdo bene
a rimanere per fare delle crocchette per
fare delle crocchette in e cantini per
fare dei croccantini per cani
avremo bisogno dei seguenti ingredienti
una zucchina 2 carote che stanno
diventando nere perché ha sbucciato
ormai da troppo tempo un nuovo tonno
crusca farina integrale e vieta
dell'ammoniaca per dolci ora calcolate
che stiamo prendendo questa ricetta da
benedetta vi lascio il link del soprano
e qua sotto ma abbastanza conosciuta per
quanto riguarda foto quindi grazie beni
quello che dice lei che l'ammoniaca per
dolci quanto abbia effettivamente un
nome pauroso non è necessaria se la
metteremo però avremo la possibilità di
avere dei dolci che si seccheranno più
facilmente in modo proprio dare quella
consistenza d'acqua crocché rino come
quello che rino croccantino
[Musica]
ricatti o anche più avanti
partiamo subito con la preparazione per
prima cosa dovremo togliere tutto quello
che ho preso e metterlo qui
prendiamo le carote le tre parole carote
che il cane non il coyote le insaporisco
con le gote piacevoli se potete
appoggiarle sulle vostre cose fidatevi
che il gusto alla fine ne risentirà in
positivo va bene anzi va bornia poi
sanno cucinare ma c'è una piccola
sorpresa perché dopo due mesi di
attività e di rientro dalle vacanze
finalmente è tornato lui cam e grembiule
prendiamo la zucchina e tagliamo la
mamma mia che giocheranno molta più
soddisfazione
[Risate]
così la porzione appunto lui distanza e
non a mangia se si scansa le mangio io
ma è impossibile che si scansa scrivere
infine rho al polo 0 una manciatina e
sta a posto
tagliamo prendiamo tutta questa roba qui
e la mettiamo a bollire in una pentola
con dell'acqua per un coperchio
e ce li dimentichiamo sembra tipo
presente quando può mitiche quello là
per fare minestrone butto immagini del
video ke skifo enrico ma siete in
maniera tutto questo no se tu fai una
lasagna ti mangi tutta la sala 6 giu si
fa questa pietanza a lungo termine cioè
dura due settimane due settimane grazie
anche all'armonia che questa da
ricordare a tutti quindi ci stanno
seguendo l'ammoniaca aiuta pure a
conservare il cibo per 15 giorni fino a
15 giorni ma è fatta dalla pelle
niente più giovane vero si no niente
devo essere sincero sto funzionare la
pelle un po screpolata era un consiglio
per tutte le persone che ci seguono da
casa quando fate bollire andate in bagno
e prendetevi del tempo per voi
mentre le verdure fanno la sauna voi
fate una beauty farm a di parma ho detto
più di far ma non è vero
più di pasta esigue replay
fate una beauty farm al avevo detto di
fare parma avvicina forse va in fiamme
questo è pazzo che lasci in pace il cane
la nostra brodaglia
cadesse proprio comico mamma mi senti io
lo faccio andare un altro pochino per
renderlo un pochino più fastoso capito
bambino dell'esorcista reagan tutto il
succo di reagan e mi ero sempre chiesto
come facessero a fare le crocchette
naturalmente metto in descrizione tutte
quante le quantità torno ragazzi a
naturale mi raccomando eh sgocciolato
bravo che cagano e scoraggiano e glorie
carapina possono i veterinari cosa che
noi abbiamo fatto un nuovo aiuto
no
io sento un odore di merda ragazza abbia
fatto roma per umani molto peggio adesso
dovrei aggiungere per ogni scodella dai
15 ai 20 cucchiaio ma noi a gianmarco ma
tu sei sul pezzo come poche cose stanno
sul pezzo simpaticissimo e nella crusca
1 2 e 3 cucchiai in farina integrale 1 2
3 cucchiai intanto partiamo prima lenti
giusto per far credito perché sennò
l'effetto raggiera di merda processo si
guarda sogna lui e pancette non è vedere
se che respirano lui sto sognando lui
come dorme l'utente dopo il mancato
caricare i video sta cominciando a
diventare 112
secondo me 15 che ai nostri su 27
mettiamo una maniera per dolci
consistenza
voto 10 incorporazione 10 3 abbiamo
adesso la nostra teglia la nostra carta
da forno importantissima capirete anche
perché qualcuno mi dia una mano
si affida molto bene a me sembra essere
uscito da un culo sono io
ecco dimostrato dai basta una specie nei
ancora bisogna iniziare a sporcare con
la si è assolutamente un teatro per
umani
ora dobbiamo appiattire tutto quanto in
maniera molto molto omogeneo il più
omogeneo possibile per i nostri piccoli
amici a quattro zampe dolcissimi ma ora
questo come norme lo vedi come dorme
ragazzi io continuo a pennellare come
manco fossi van gogh
io sono sicura che aveva messo un cane
col pennello e il quadro di van gogh
davanti a questo punto in forno a 180
gradi per 40 minuti si è fatta notte i
cuccioletti si sono svegliati e questo
caso non è che abbia proprio una
bellissima faccia posso dirlo sembra un
campo a ottimo per il presepe no gommosi
non come fatto causa al sito rosa perché
dopo li rimettiamo infine si fregia vi
mettiamo in forno forno caldo per 15
minuti che dovrebbe seccarli meglio
infatti si leggono quelli che sono
arrabbiatissima posso dire che quasi con
cifre impegnate mie sfascerò gli assaggi
rai ci stanno dentro cose che ti magni
benissimo alle 6 maniero cose molto
peggio di questo secondo me quindi tu
stai proponendo di assaggiare i
croccantini del cane se io ho già fatto
il tuo croccantino abbiamo tagliato un
pochino di tutta quella roba anche
perché sennò non c'era abbastanza spazio
fra i vari croccantini lo mettiamo forno
cantina me lo dice benedetto xvi a forno
caldo 10 15
questa sera notevole niente pure le
serre croccanti si è arrivato il momento
che tutti quanti aspettavamo il momento
dell'assaggio prima di far assaggiare al
nostro degustatore di masterchef canino
il piatto vi ricordo che se non siete
iscritti a questo canale potete sempre
farlo qui sotto
se non sbaglio c'è cosa per iscriversi e
attivando la campanella delle notifiche
la sede si una zampa in su qualora vi
fosse piaciuto questo video e adesso
credo che sia arrivato il momento il
momento della pasta
facciamo un assaggio da qui perché sta
scomodo da allora che cosa che è
piaciuto a nessuno ti presenta nel senso
scusami che se ti metto giù lo mangi
fammi vedere guardate la bravura di
questo cane no no no no no dopo mister
ma ti piace questo bagaglino scomodo
curdo
e adesso si no non ti prendi più te lo
prendi questo colposo tacchio ha detto
che la juve detto io me lo mangio quindi
tu il pezzo più polposo di arrivo perché
riprendere bene pubblico questa altro
pezzo sempre e comunque il vero tu sei
ma io prendo questo c'è il cambio quasi
cantiere veneroso aveva costituito il
diamo appunto lo diciamo ben dire che il
cane è soddisfatto ha un cane
soddisfatto by che praileau paura dal
cibo domani sarò in zona cava regala
tranquilli o senza cagata commestibile
come sembrano andare non lo darei il mio
cane aspetta l aver già cagata proprio
ma tra tutte le ricette che hai fatto
forse anche un buon ampie sono d'accordo
questa questo sapore dolceamaro ecco che
vorrei chiudere questa puntata di cucina
buttata c'è la prossima domenica ragazzi
vado a infilarmi nel freezer
ciao